a judge has ordered Donald Trump to
dissolve the Trump organization I didn't
believe it when I first heard it because
this is the most egregious action I
think we've seen yet it's not just
trying to criminally charge him which is
crazy don't get me wrong but they're
outright saying they are they're going
to shut down this what multi-billion
dollar real estate company at least it's
just in New York so we'll see how this
plays out Trump is going to appeal but
man I don't see it stopping here it is
not even 2024 yet but wait many of you
may be saying well what's going to
happen I mean Trump's leading in the
polls he is Joe Biden's failing among
Black and Latino voters but now we're
learning that the classified document
probe into Joe Biden is expanding and
Gavin Newsom in the prediction markets
is starting to go up so maybe I'll be
I'll be really happy if by next year I'm
I'm right that Joe Biden ends up being
removed or drops out or something
because I'm like crossing my fingers I'm
like please don't be wrong because I
just cannot see a path